hey good evening guys this is Q&A Sunday
with me Samuel lids and I love to take
an opportunity just to sit back look at
all the niggling property questions that
you guys have and drawn out into some as
best I possibly can so the last week we
had some really good questions as usual
we had Jamila
van uma Iraqi I hope I pronounced that
right as always struggling hi Samuel
what are the tools you would recommend
to take when viewing properties accept a
mandatory tape measure the tools that I
recommend taking when I do viewings do
you know what I like really take
anything I don't even take a tape
measure that often yeah I can pretty
much measure a room with my feet because
my foot is like a foot long and I just
walk along the room sometimes take your
tape measure because it looks
professional and I also like to just if
I'm talking with the vendor I just
pretend to measure stuff more talking
and asking questions it's like it takes
away from the confrontation a little bit
a notepad absolutely although I'll
usually use my phone to be honest you
you can go super impaired you could when
I used to go for viewings it was like a
big deal oh my gosh I got a viewing so I
get a tape measure I bring a little
notebook and a pen I'd bring comparables
of all the other properties that sold in
the street and and all the research that
I don't on the house I'd bring a camera
and I take photos and I'll spend like up
to an hour in the house sometimes but
now if I did that every time I viewed a
house I don't think I'd ever sleep
because I viewed that many houses and I
think the really important thing is I
will say this the person the views the
most houses wins
so rather than a bit like getting all
the equipment and spending ages I'd
rather view ten houses in one day and
spend 10 15 minutes in each house then
spent then view three houses and spend
an hour in each house so I just get out
there view the houses also relationships
really important I always say again it's
better to have a good relationship with
an agent than a good deal so I'll just
few loads of houses get in with loads of
agents if the house isn't good and I
don't like the house rather than just
leaving and not saying anything
I'll tell the agent or maybe not the
vendor
if it's the only house - then doors got
but if it's with an agent I'll tell them
I don't like it I'll say I don't like
this house this is why it doesn't work
1 2 3 have you got anything that could
work for me and it's just I see it as an
opportunity to build rapport and also to
educate the agent so I think the most
important thing to take in there is your
skillset just and your brain your
experience your ability to speak to
people that's the most important thing
you can bring to a viewing rather than
special tools and equipment I do it so I
hope that answers your question let's
see what else we got
guest one two three four five who says
hey Samuel how do you find builders or
contractors in different areas around
the UK to renovate or refurbish your
properties great question
builders are tricky because even if you
find a good builder they might be good
for a bit and then turn bad because what
builders do when they get busy is they
they either get really sloppy or they
try and replace themself and grow their
team and bring other builders in but the
other builder might not be good but they
are so even if you've got a good builder
lesson number one a good builder for
life
in my experience doesn't exist they'll
be good for a bit and then just when you
begin to trust them enough to not have
to project manage them they'll then turn
bad and happy how do you find a good one
in the first place I usually find good
builders by referrals so if I'm moving
into a new area I'll go to Facebook and
I'll ask hey I'm looking for a builder
in such as a Janerio anyone can anyone
recommend anybody sometimes I'll take
builders with me so if I've got builders
who are based in Birmingham and I'm
doing a job in Coventry which is maybe
40 minutes away I'll just ask them to
travel and pay them a little bit more
because I'd rather have someone good on
the job then that then pays slightly
more for their travel then find a whole
new building team or a new builder
Facebook's a good way also networking go
to property networking events and in the
area and say I've got some projects very
rarely do I just start ringing up people
off of off yellow pages I mean it's
always it's always referrals and then
another thing
well when you when you have a builder
make sure that you don't pay them
upfront why not have people to get let's
say I got screwed over by my builder the
only reason you got screwed over was
because you were irresponsible because
you paid upfront
most people that say they got screwed
over by the Builder set the Builder up
to screw them over so pay up don't pay
up front you can pay a little bit up
front if they're doing like a 20,000
pound refurb you can pay maybe three
thousand pound upfront and then they get
started and then paint in stages so
that's also really important and make
sure that someone it doesn't have to be
even make sure when there's builders on
site doing what someone is checking up
on them because if you leave them to it
no matter how good they are human nature
they're not going to do as good of a job
if no one's there checking up on them so
that's kind of generally what I do with
builders I'll do a video at some point
I'll do a video of me going out there
finding builders and working with them
so on maybe a TV Tuesday for sure but
Salim in Ram says how do I know if an
area is oversaturated and how do I know
which areas are the best to invest in
okay ask people ask people that know the
answer so if it's oversaturated
oversaturated with I assume you mean
investors trying to rent their houses
out there for there's not there's not a
shortage of houses to rent that's
usually what people mean when they say
oversaturated so if you're wanting to do
to do a hey chip to buy a house and turn
it into a high gem oh but there's loads
of people buying houses and turn them to
take some owners in that area every man
needs dog and there's thousands of rooms
then that could be oversaturated for
HMOs if it's oversaturated for single
let's it's not usually I mean the price
will just come down a little bit I
always say everything will went out at
the right price you just need to figure
out what the right price is so if it's
over such as people ring up letting
agents ring up investors in the area
ring up HMO management companies if it's
HMO and just say to them you know what's
the market like what the best what the
best streets in this in this city
what would you went out in a week and
what could take months and now usually
just tell you
and never buy a property off one
person's say so always remember that
everyone's always got an agenda you just
need to figure out what their agenda is
so sometimes when I ring up letting
agents I'll ring them as a tenant and
say you know hey I'm looking for a
property to rent what's going down what
you got how much would you be looking
for what are the best areas I'm not from
tap I'm not from I'm not from town and
you'll find that they'll be very very
honest with you yeah you don't want to
you don't waste people's time but if
you're genuinely looking to buy in the
area and you are genuinely wanting to
buy and you'll need a Layton agent
that's just called market research so
another thing you can do is put up a
dummy ad so on places like open rent you
can put adverts and spare room code at
UK if you take time and you can put up
you can put bad verts and you don't know
waste people's time so if you put up if
you put a dummy add on spare room and
someone phones you and says oh I'm
looking for your room you know don't
just go how high it was it was a test or
always gone and then waste their time
what what I would do is I would if
someone rang me and said oh I saw your
advert I would say this one's not ready
yet
slash doesn't exist but let me put you
in touch with someone who has a similar
room and then past the plus the
inquiries over then you've got a new
best friend over here because this
landlord is going to be laughs thanks
for personal and then that's always good
because relationships always better than
a deal so these are some ways that you
can do your market research in regards
to what the best areas depends on your
strategy if you're looking at doing
straightforward bye-bye to rent by to
let bar low rent high you know you're
gonna get a much better return working
in an area where by house prices are
cheaper but the rents are the same
because there's no direct correlation
between the house price and the rent so
you want to find somewhere where you can
buy it low or rent it high a whole lot
of areas but hopefully that was helpful
Kieran Shwa okay Samuel you say you
don't buy where you live but getting a
buy to let mortgage for a first-time
buyer is next to impossible how do we as
first-time buyers get around that
great question firstly it's not
impossible it's very possible a lot of
my students are buying
properties and renting the houses out
and they don't even own a house then
they're not all residential oh no at all
so it's very very possible you need a
good broker I've had a lot of people
challenge me on this and I'll hold you
to what I said which is rent where you
live and rent out what you own so in
other words be a telling yourself but
then just have lots of other tenants
I'll stand by that generally speaking
unless you are one in a situation in
life where you've got so much money and
you just love a house and you buy in
your dream house and you know that
commercially it's probably not the best
thing to do but you just want to live in
that house forever and you've got the
money to buy it and it doesn't matter
because you're already financially free
no problem or sometimes people have said
to me they don't own anything and
they've got a little bit of money and
they say Samuel it works out better for
me to buy a residential house and living
it than to buy a buy to let and
sometimes it's true because you can put
down such a small deposit and you can
also get yourself up on the ladder ready
to buy better type of deals so sometimes
it can work out better to buy a house
for yourself what I'm really against is
people working really hard saving it up
and then getting 50 grand and then
dumping it into a house to live in when
they could have used that money to buy a
buy to level by three by two lets and
then the rent that they receive rent
where they live live in a better house
have excess income I'm really against
that but occasionally if your big
picture is I want to be financially free
and you have done the numbers and you're
confident that buying a house to live in
is going to get you faster to financial
freedom than buying a house to buy to
let then fine
but nine times out of ten that's not the
case we need to move away from this
having to own everything you can you can
you can live a really good life and rent
stuff you'd have to own everything so it
broke people say you know I've gotta own
house and paid off the mortgage as
quickly as possible rich people say I
want to own assets and then with those
assets live a really good life so I hope
that was helpful if you've got questions
no matter how specific I'm pointed and
niggly they are comment below get your
comment you get your comments and
questions below and I'll choose out at
least four to answer for next week and I
hope you find the helpful don't forget
to subscribe and I'll look for juicing
you tomorrow for the next video we do
videos every day man every day I'm doing
a video so you better subscribe because
the more subscribers the more views the
more comments the more likes the more Fr
put into doing these because I mean more
people are watching so subscribe I'll
see you next time
you